Hi, I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk a little bit about
adapting technique. I know I talk about
this a lot, but it's because I feel like
it's pivotal to understanding what's
going on in Iikido and yet most Iikido
schools never talk about adaptation of
techniques. Um, so that's that's it. I'm
gonna call Josh over here if you're
ready to work.
Josh. All right. So, let's let's talk
about adapting technique. I have
probably you guys are probably like man
well we need another video on adapting
technique but I feel like when I started
realizing that techniques have to adapt
and like that's why I was doing
Brazilian jiu-jitsu when I was doing
Brazilian jitsu I understood I was like
oh yeah techniques have to adapt like
not just that I do something totally
different but that I adapt the technique
I'm doing and that's how I build a
really solid game. But when I started
realizing that for I kid I was like oh
man all the techniques really adapt
nicely like someone thought it out at
some point. Um and uh we need to have
all those techniques and the ways in
which those techniques adapt, right? So
let's look at something real real
simple. So actually let's let's look at
eekio and and I I've shown you the
urinote drill, I believe. So if you
haven't seen the uramote drill, um check
out that because it'll it'll talk a lot
about this. So the basic Udamote drill
is I come in to do eeky mote on Josh. If
he's easy to push, then I push him. If I
come in and I hit a roadblock, I go
urazo, right? I turn turn to the
backside. Okay? Okay. And you could do
that with edemia or sultamori. It
doesn't matter. Okay. So that is the
root of what's going on. I try one thing
and it doesn't work this way. So I just
immediately adapt to the next thing.
Right? And that's what you want to
always be able to do. And you want to be
able to do that on the drop of a dime.
The faster and more efficiently you can
adapt to the next technique when one's
not working, the more likely you are to
stay ahead of this guy. So understand if
I hit Josh, I'm already ahead, right?
I'm ahead. So, so whether he blocks, it
doesn't matter what he does, I'm ahead.
Even if he gets out of the way, I'm
still ahead because I'm dictating what
Josh does. So, I'm ahead of Josh in
time. Now, the more I can stay ahead of
Josh in time, the better it will turn
out for me. As I start to get behind
Josh in time, then Josh will be making
plans for me, and I'll be reactive to
Josh. And that means I always first have
to react to Josh, then I have to do
something to overcome and make Josh
react to me. So, it's it's complicated
and a pain in the butt, but this is the
way it always works. So, the faster I
can be at changing something, then the
harder it is for him to keep up with me
and the more likely I'll win. And this
goes back to um uh uh Boyd's uh loop
udaloop and and that whole idea and and
there's more videos coming on that
actually very soon. Um so, check that
out. But you just want to stay ahead of
the other guy. Okay. Now, in iikido, how
can that work? It can work a million
ways, right? So, let's say I'm up here
and like I said before, he pushed
against me. I could use the udrawaza,
right? Let's say I'm up here and he
starts wanting to drive his elbow down.
I could go into nikyo. Let's say I'm
right here and I can't push here and I
go urowaza and nothing happens. I can go
into sanio, right? Let's say I'm up here
and I need a little more oomph forward.
I can go into yonko. Uh let's say I'm up
here and he straightens his arm out. I
can go into rokyo, right? Um I I would
show a gokyo, but it doesn't happen real
nice from there. Okay.
So, anytime I adapt one technique into
the next, tons of techniques naturally
link really easily. And you should be
real familiar with those. For example,
Rokio, if he bends his arm to keep me
from rokoing him, turns into kagash and
kagash, if he's fighting me, will often
lock into royo, right? So, those two
link supernaturally together, right?
Supernaturally. So, they they they link
together in a really natural way. You
got to understand those naturally come
one and two like that, right? Most of
the the iikido techniques that sit side
by side in the kiosa echo through they
naturally turn one into the next really
nicely as well. So what you need to do
is familiarize yourself with all the
pairs that work really really well
together. Now most of the time iikido
techniques are given to us in that same
format. Right? So let's look at um
kitateori kitanag and there's the
uchimawari variation and the stoi
variation. Okay. Now in the the basic
idea for this technique is as I read it
is to hit him and escape. Boom. And get
out of there. Okay. But what if I hit
him and I don't escape? Well, the
natural thing to go is uchimari. Boom.
Now the kitanag would be if he kept
coming around to me and as he comes
around to me, boom. That sets up a
kitanag. That's how the uh uchim moari
kitanag from katadori sets up. But look,
watch what happens if I go here and I
go, oh, I'm going to sink under and he
blocks that. How would he block that?
That's how he would block it. And look
what I did. I did the sootari and the
same variation or the stoi variation
will come off that. So, same technique,
kiteag, different variation samorei. So,
the techniques are often given to us in
pairs. That's why we have and emote
techniques for so many things because
they're telling us what those opposing
and adapting methods are. Now, I
generally call these complatory
opposites. When I work one thing and
they block it, there will be a new set
of advantages on that one thing. And you
have to understand to the letter which
each one of those are. And it it will
become eventually it will become um
unconscious mind stuff and not conscious
mind stuff. But first work through it
consciously. You'll get good at that by
working through lots of kaishiwaza. Have
I made a kaiishiwaza video for this? All
right. Well, if I haven't, I will make
one. If I have made one, then I will
link it below. Um, so if not, then next
week you guys will get a Kaiwaz video.
But Kaiishiwaz is a good way to start to
understand what all the complatory
opposites are and how you adapt one
technique into another technique, etc.
So forth, but understand that they're
pretty much already given to you. It's
just for me anyways, maybe you guys have
figured this out, but for me, I was real
obtuse and didn't figure this out for a
long time till I was like, "Oh, they
tell us what those are all the time."
But all right, so I think that's that's
good. So that's that's basically
adapting technique. I'm Christopher
Fines. Joshua T again. My Slaughter
McDaniel that camera over there. We'll
see you in the next video. Hey, I'm
Christopher Hind. So if you made it all
the way through this video, chances are
you kind of liked the way I presented
stuff or were so irritated by it that
you wanted to watch more of it. So I
have a Patreon page. Maybe that's just
for you. You should check it out. There
are literally hundreds of videos on that
Patreon page. I've been making videos
for Patreon since I think 2020 or 2021.
Uh, and I've been making somewhere
between two and five a week. So, there
are tons of videos up over there. So,
you might want to check that out. It's
patreon.com. Christopherhine. Uh, hope
to see you there.